what is up everybody happy Wednesday
morning I am freshly shaved ready for
another gratitude journal live stream
number 13 the idea here is we share
daily the things that we agreed before
to help us stay happier help us stay
focused on the things that are important
to us help us stay stay on track for our
goals not get too discouraged because we
have a lot of great things already
around us so this is a daily habit I do
with my team I brought it to you guys
two most important factors are 1 again
its daily whether you're doing with me
daily what they do with yourself daily
whatever it's a daily practice so that
you don't fall off the trainings that
you're consistently grateful for the
things in your life it's important the
other part is that you really feel it
you know whatever whatever is that
you're grateful for is not just the list
but you actually deeply feel it if you
want to get the benefits of gratitude
then then that's super important so how
this works I'm going to share three
things that I'm week before I want you
guys in a live tried to share three
things you are grateful for this morning
and then those are you watching after
the replay leave it down in the comments
below three things that you're great
before I promise you it'll make a big
difference in your life if you continue
to do it consistently over time so I'm
going to start off three things that I
earn grateful for number one for me I'm
going to go with Martin Martin is one of
the belief nation fans he is also a
league of legends player who is way
higher up in the rankings and I am and
he reached out to me and want to give me
some advice on my gameplay and so we
were chatting a little bit last night
and he gave me some some tips that I
gotta apply in a few minutes on the next
league of legends live stream and I was
appreciative to him for his tips and his
feedback and his love and wanted to help
out and yeah just a great a reflection
of
all you guys all of believe nation
trying to help trying to give back
trying to spread some good and so I was
feeling the love last night with Martin
next up I'm going to go with my Toronto
Blue Jays I've been a baseball fan uh
for as long as I can remember I want
every year to spring training and still
do now continue to tradition with my son
and love the Blue Jays and it's awesome
to see them in the in the hunt for the
playoff spot we're watching last night
as the Blue Jays of playing the
Baltimore Orioles and everyone and this
is just such an excitement that it's you
know at times a silly that you know
you're cheering on these people that
have nothing to do with you has no
impact really on your life but the city
pride and just the joy that I get when I
see the team win and I'm celebrating
with Nina and Hayden as we're watching
so super excited then hopefully again
this should be in the playoffs hopefully
they get farlax I mean a wild-card spot
but super there's an excitement around
the city right now there's a buzz it's
only going to get stronger as we head
into the playoffs and so I'm grateful
for that and I'm feeling it and number 3
i'm gonna go with silicon valley the TV
show Alex mentioned it this morning and
it's a it's a show that I've watched all
three seasons of a big fan it chronicles
the life of some entrepreneurs and
Silicon Valley's are building up their
business and the ups and downs and it's
it's a satire is a lot there's a lot of
sarcastic comments and kind of pokes a
little bit of fun at the venture capital
industry in Silicon Valley and me being
a former venture capitalist some of the
jokes may not make total sense if you
don't get the industry but but I love
the show and just before this I was
looking at a at one of my
clips from the show with Alex and kind
of cracking up and so I love that
there's entrepreneur related TV shows
out there as well because it's not a lot
you think of how many entrepreneurs are
are there there aren't that many
entrepreneur TV shows there's obviously
sharks tank the profit but there's not
it's not that much out there so it's
great to see some drama out there for
entrepreneurs to give us give us some
love with the TV show guys so let's hit
up the the live chat what do you guys
people for you to read out some comments
jay wray starting this up early usually
I start by saying when you get before in
the chat and he beat me to the punch
this morning so I love that Rishi cup TV
one grateful for learning freedom to
learn about whatever we want grateful
for my hair it takes so long to do in
the morning so long to do in the morning
but I'm thankful for it I feel you this
is like an hour and a half to get it
looking like this and three grateful for
the YouTube Cup munity like that her one
word is cup so I like that J reyez
thankful for muscle bone and enamel he's
taken he's taken the the body part of
the day away from zaino here muscle bone
and enamel thankful for smiles and
laughter thank for the earth and all it
provides thankful for the ease of bank
machines I'm not a big fan of the bank
machines but they charge you if you go
to somebody else's bank machine but I
totally agree man i love it i love i
love how how that gratitude spot there
really fills a wide variety of things
from body parts to the earth to bank
machines i love it what else antoine
good morning good morning antoine muscle
and bone anthony my at ola ola ola ola
everyone ola anthony welcome what do we
got when we got antoine cream for water
that helps me with my migraines stay
hydrated people has a big impact man i
drink two of these every day
and it helps I remember being on a live
hangout with with Christopher Gavigan
who's the co-founder of the honest
company and he was going on about that
to you have had a drink water water
water water water water much morning
y'all drinking some now uh yeah welcome
good morning much 6am in portland happy
water drinking in chocolate eating
that's what she always eats for
breakfast there what else we got cup of
chai latte millville hey all what's up
man how was a superstar that is Rishi
today from Anthony Wow Rishi the
superstar I'm loving that entwine
grateful for crowdfunding that really
helps love that you come in to twitch
after we're going to be doing twitch Wow
one minute it's a crazy how quickly it
goes we talking business and playing
league what else what else bool I
grateful for a good breakfast I love it
great way to start the day what else
what else sharing grateful for tooth
brush floss and birds I love it grateful
for living on a golf cart golf course a
golf cart golf course and no broken
windows Anthony grateful for my amazing
Klein's to live in one of the world's
greatest cities and the fact that it's
one month till I travel again I love a
good luck good luck traveling there
Anthony what else what else what else
apparently water also helps with
arthritis Cornell lynnwood water is the
juice nectar of the gods well that's it
guys nine ten hope you guys have an
amazing day we're going to head off to
twitch play some league and answer some
business questions I have an amazing day
feel that gratitude carried into your
day I'm gonna go do video day after
today so I'm feeling your energy and
bringing it to my videos so I have some
content for the week thank you guys for
joining continue to believe or whatever
your one word is gonna say soon